der verzicht auf kontrolle einer million
flut von illegalen hat deutschlands
schwersten schaden zugefügt künftig
hunderte milliarden kosten asyl und
sozialbetrug import von islamisten und
gefährdern unendliches menschliches leid
durch vergewaltiger und mörder
messerstecher und terroristen all das
haben sie zu verantworten ein
schrecklicher preis für ihr freundliches
gesicht warum haben sie nicht
rechtzeitig umgesteuert wann ziehen sie
endlich auch persönlich die konsequenz
aus dem fortgesetzten bruch ihres
amtseides und stellen sich ihrer
verantwortung wann treten sie zurück
wir hatten im jahr 2015 das deutete sich
schon 2014 an eine außergewöhnliche
humanitäre situation in der deutschland
verantwortlich gehandelt hat und im
übrigen durch den europäischen
gerichtshof mit seinem urteil vom juli
2017 auch bestätigt rechtmäßigen handeln
die politischen grundentscheidungen
waren richtig und trotzdem haben wir
inzwischen eine vielzahl von maßnahmen
durchgeführt die deutlich macht dass es
sich um eine ausnahmesituation gehandelt
hat ich habe hierzu ausführlich in
meiner regierungserklärung zu beginn der
legislaturperiode stellung genommen und
sehr deutlich gemacht dass wir seitdem
vieles verändert haben und auch weiter
verändern werden
ich möchte den bankmitarbeitern ihrer
großen mehrheit danken für ihre arbeit
denn sie haben in einer außergewöhnlich
schwierigen situation in einer behörde
gearbeitet die gewachsen ist angewachsen
ist von etwa 2.400 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in der end in der zahl der
höchsten von über 9.000 mitarbeitern das
war eine große leistung gerade auch herr
weise hat hier ordnung und steuerung
hereingebracht mit seinem wissen über
die aufstellung der bundesagentur für
arbeit und deshalb müssen wir weiter
arbeiten aber in der humanitären
auslandshilfe
vielen dank